With everything now set up we have reached the end of this tutorial series.
Now to quickly recap we first started off by going over some of the more
common blueprint nodes we'd be utilizing in the workshop. We then did
the same with Unreal Motion Graphics or UMG and inside of the workshop we
took our vehicle template and we set it up so that we could create a
score and time pickup that then relayed this information to the user while the
game was running. Once the game was over the user's final score was taken and
displayed to them and the user was given the option to run the game another time.
We also created a main menu that allows the user to actually start the
project and remember your take home for this is to create both a quit and a
restart allowing you to either quit or restart or go back to the main menu
depending on what options you wish. It was my great pleasure having you in
today's tutorial and I look forward to seeing you next time.